when you have a vision long term that
you're excited about current issues
don't stress you out they don't every
one of your competitors many of them
that are not going to make you the next
two years I can guarantee you right now
90 of them out there thinking about is
today so I'm going to tell you I
guarantee you because I had a lot of
guys that I went up against in the last
20 something years that were bigger than
me smarter than me better degrees better
markets better background better
accolades better speakers better
everything they look better they look
like somebody that would be a seal of an
insurance company do I look like a CEO
of an insurance company I look like a
bodyguard from the Middle East I don't
look like a Sylvan insurance company a
typical insurance agent was a 50
six-year-old white male I asked the guy
said what percentage of insurance agents
are from Iran I was like what are you
talking about
I said out of all these Asians we have
in America what percentage are Iranian I
said no listen Pat you guys are in the
other section
there's white then it's Asian then it's
Hispanic then it's black then it's this
then it's that you're in the other
section less than one percent